670,000
pounds. That's not the weight of his
ego. It's what he has to pay for his
bogus defamation lawsuit. It's the cost
of his ego. 670,000.
That is a lot of DA donations going
straight into the pocket of Douglas
Murray. If you're a Muhammad hijab fan,
you might as well start paying your
zakat directly to Douglas Murray because
that's where your money's going for a
long, long time.
What can I possibly say about Muhammad
hijab that hasn't already been said
about the Hindenburg?
At least the Hindenburg didn't try to
take down a bunch of its fellow
zeppelins when it went down in flames.
Muhammad Hijab, by contrast, wants
everyone to know that if his DA career
is over, he's taking the whole Dawa
circus down with him. So why the total
implosion? And why now? And what can we
learn from this DA dumpster fire that
never gets put out because of the
endless careers that keep it burning?
We're about to find out. But first,
let's make sure everyone's up to date.
Just a few months ago, Muhammad Hijab
was exposed for his now infamous hotel
wife scandal. We eventually found out
that Hijab had a team of 75 Daagandists
conspiring to destroy a woman's life.
All because she wanted to warn other
Muslim women about how the Dawa diddy
gangs are treating Muslim women behind
the scenes. The truth came out and the
credibility of dozens of hijab's allies
has been shattered. As if that weren't
bad enough for team Dawa, we now have
Douglas Murray bragging about his
victory over Muhammad Hijab. Yes, after
being thoroughly humiliated by a woman,
Hijab has been humiliated again, this
time by a gay man half his size. Murray
writes, "Three years ago, I wrote a
column in this magazine about some of
the downsides of diversity. At the time,
there had just been serious disturbances
in Lester. Yes, Americans, it's
pronounced Lester. It's where John
Merrick, aka the Elephant Man, was born.
Between local Hindus and Muslims, one of
the people who decided to throw himself
into the middle of that trouble,
hopefully not in the Alz sense, and to
try to make things worse, was an online
pugilist known as Muhammad Hijab. Hijab
had already been filmed intimidating
Jews in Golders's Green and whipping up
a crowd of masked men outside the
Israeli embassy in London. In Leicester,
he chose to make a derogatory speech
about Hindus to a crowd of men and then
picture himself leading a Muslim patrol
in the city. Say it ain't so, Muhammad
Hijab. The Da Champ wouldn't stir up
hatred against Jews and Hindus, would
he? And if he did, this big strong
daagandist wouldn't run to British
courts, begging them to protect him from
criticism like a sniveling little
coward, would he?
After I pointed this out, Hijab tried to
sue me and the spectator. I retained the
excellent Mark Lewis as my lawyer, and
for years, along with the magazine's
brilliant legal team, RPC, we watched
Hijab perform every known legal and
rhetorical contortion. Hijab's lawyers
repeatedly dragged out their case,
avoided every opportunity to drop it and
insisted not only that what I had
written was untrue, but that hijab had
suffered serious emotional and mental
distress. Poor guy seems really fragile,
as well as financial loss as a result.
Hijab seemed to think that he could use
the courts not just to pursue me, but to
debate me.
I have to say I would have loved to see
Douglas Murray debate Muhammad hijab,
but sadly it won't happen because hijab
won't be facing any serious debaters
after this train wreck.
Last month the case was heard in London
before Mr. Justice Johnson. Many of
Hijab's witnesses failed to show up
claiming ill health or having appeared
to have skipped the country. Hijab
himself spent several days in the
witness box.
Why wouldn't many of hijab's witnesses
show up to testify for him last month?
Because this was after the hotel wife
scandal and they realized hijab just
isn't worth defending. They don't want
to get sucked into the black hole that
this dawa star has become.
This week, the judge delivered his
verdict. Mr. Justice Johnson found that
what I had said in my article was
accurate, that hijab had hurt his own
reputation more through his actions and
social media posts than I could have
ever done with my article, and that the
number of lies hijab told in court were
so numerous that his evidence overall is
worthless.
So, what I've been saying for years now
has the stamp of approval of a UK judge.
The judgment also noted that as well as
being combative and constantly
argumentative when cross-examined by my
barristister and the spectator's
barristister, hijab also demonstrated a
palpable personal animosity towards your
columnist.
To be fair, hijab demonstrates a
palpable personal animosity towards
anyone who doesn't mindlessly agree with
everything he says because he's a
narcissist.
The judgment found that hijab lied about
events in Golders's Green, which he
refused to accept was a Jewish area. It
found that he had lied about his
demagoguic and dangerous actions outside
the Israeli embassy in London, that he
had lied about events in Leicester, and
that he had lied about and indeed
appeared to have concocted his claim of
lost earnings. These lost earnings were
alleged to have come from three Muslim
organizations, including a supplements
company called Nature's Blends. All
claimed to have been big readers of my
spectator column, as indeed, Hijab
alleged, causing him yet more hurt, was
a receptionist at his local gym. Maybe
he wanted her as another hotel wife.
Witnesses to his alleged financial loss
failed to attend court. Another, Mr. Was
from Nature's Blends had to try to
explain his recent conviction and time
spent in prison for making false court
claims after staging car accidents.
Yes, Hijab's star witness was a man who
had been sent to prison for fraud. These
guys are tactical geniuses. Douglas
Murray's article continues, but I'd like
to read a few hilarious excerpts from
the judge's ruling right after a brief
word about this video's sponsor. People
like Muhammad Hijab and his fans are
constantly trying to stir up hostility
towards Jews, Christians, Hindus, even
towards Muslims who happen to be from
the wrong sect of Islam. The sad part is
that they're often successful and a lot
of the people who suffer the
consequences are ordinary people trying
to live their lives and provide for
their families. But haters like hijab
have been taking some heavy losses
lately. Let's give them another L by
supporting Christian and Jewish artisans
who are struggling because of the
economic jihad against Israel. Tens of
thousands of small businesses in Israel,
many of them small family businesses,
fell apart in the aftermath of the
attacks in 2023.
This was all part of the plan of the
jihadis. But there's a way to help
Israeli Christians and Jews who've been
caught in the economic crossfire. Artza
is a company that gathers products made
by small businesses in Israel, Jewish
and Christian businesses, and some
charities, and they send them to you in
a box. Some of these small businesses
only survived the past 2 years because
they could sell items to people like us
through Artza. You'll get candles,
Israeli spice mixes, olivewood carvings,
mosaic art, decorations, cosmetics,
candy, games, all kinds of things
delivered right to your door. So, let's
not let jihadis destroy more small
businesses in Israel. Sign up to receive
a quarterly arts box. Use the link in
the description to get a discount and to
let them know who sent you. Now, back to
our good friend Muhammad Hijab and the
impression he made in court. From the
judge's ruling as a witness, he Muhammad
Hijab was combative and constantly
argumentative. He sought at every turn
to debate with counsel, responding to
questions with rhetorical questions of
his own, arguing his case rather than
giving straightforward responses, and
denigrating the character of the second
defendant to whom he bears palpable
personal animosity. I am satisfied that
he lied on significant issues with the
consequence that his evidence overall is
worthless. Funny, that's exactly what we
conclude whenever we watch one of
hijab's dawa videos. Specifically, I am
satisfied that he lied in respect of the
event at Golders's Green, the
counterprotest at the Rally for Israel,
the seminar on Hinduism at the Sapiens
Institute, his repudiation of
vigilantism, his evidence as to the
involvement of the Hindutva, his
evidence about his choice of language in
his speech, and his evidence in support
of his claim for financial losses. I
address each in turn. The judge indeed
goes through each of Hijab's claims in
turn and he concludes over and over
again that Hijab is a liar. The denial
that he was using the van as a prop and
his assertion that the van had nothing
to do with him was untrue. Again, that
is not credible. This is untrue. That is
not tenable. That assertion on the
claimant's own evidence is untrue. The
claimant denied that he was aware of the
throwing of eggs and bottles. That
denial is not credible. Not credible.
The claimant's oral evidence on this
point is inconsistent with both his
witness statement and what he said to
the police officer. His denial of
vigilantism is self-defeating. It is
untenable. The claimant's account as to
his basis for attributing responsibility
to the hinduta does not withstand
scrutiny. The claimant's explanation is
nonsensical.
When asked to name anyone in the world
who subscribed to the Hindutva ideology,
but who was not Hindu, he was able to
give only one name, Benjamin Netanyahu.
Even on its own terms, the claimant's
rationalization does not work. Hijab
made quite the impression in court, and
the judge doesn't seem to be a fan. He
says the description of the claimant as
a street agitator who has whipped up a
mob on London's streets and as someone
who addressed an anti-Israel protest in
inflammatory terms is an accurate
description of what the claimant is seen
to do at the rally for Israel. And now
for the dismissal. The defendants are
each responsible for the article which
conveys the following meaning. The
claimant is a street agitator who has
whipped up a mob on London's streets,
addressed an anti-Israel protest in
inflammatory terms, and exacerbated
frayed tensions, which had already
spilled over into public disorder,
between Muslim and Hindu communities in
Leicester by whipping up his Muslim
followers, including by ridiculing
Hindus for their belief in reincarnation
and describing Hindus as pathetic, weak,
and cowardly in comparison to whom he
would rather be an animal. That meaning
is a statement of fact which is
defamatory of the claimant at common
law. The publication has not caused and
is not now likely to cause serious harm
to the claimment's reputation. In any
event, it is substantially true and it
is not materially inaccurate. The claims
are accordingly dismissed.
Dismissed.
That's the judge's reaction to Hijab's
antics. Let's read just a little bit
more. This time from someone who was
observing Hijab's behavior in court.
Muhammad Hijab sat at the back of the
courtroom and ate donuts.
Lay off the donuts, Hijab, while his
lawyer, Mark Henderson, delivered his
closing submission. You will have seen
that my client is argumentative. Can be
provocative, said Henderson. Some people
might think that he is a bit of a smart
alec, a bit too cocky. Hijab reclined in
his chair and licked the sugar from his
fingers. This was Hijab's lawyer calling
him argumentative and provocative. And
Hijab and his donut fingers did not
disappoint. Hijab acted like a school
boy throughout last month's 4day trial
at the royal courts of justice. He
laughed and shouted while giving
evidence. It's an unsalvageable case,
Greg. It really is," he yelled at the
spectator's legal counsel, Greg Callus,
at the end of his second day in the
stand, leaning over the side. I guess
Hijab got one thing right. The case was
unsalvageable.
Just not in the way hijab thought. When
Hijab was not shouting, smirking,
lolling in his chair, or eating donuts,
he looked at a printout of Douglas's
column, the one he was suing over, with
Douglas's caricature at the top. Hijab
had been desperate to debate Douglas for
years and had hoped that the two would
meet in court. In the end, he didn't get
the satisfaction because Douglas wisely
decided not to attend.
So, why is Hijab sinking like the
Titanic after crashing into an iceberg
named Douglas Murray? This is an example
of an interesting problem faced by
manipulators who get a huge following on
social media. A manipulator is someone
who gets what he wants in life by duping
other people into doing what he wants
for him. The da scene is wide open for
manipulators. All you have to do is
convince the ummah that you're the hero
who's going to stop their children from
becoming apostates and they will give
you anything you want. Attention, views,
money, endless hotel wives, anything.
But manipulators are affected in turn by
the people they manipulate. A
manipulator will try something and see
if it works. If it works, he'll do more
of it. If it doesn't work, he'll try
something else and see what happens. So,
hijab conditions his followers, but they
condition him in return. Think about
this. The manipulator trains people to
do what he wants, but the people he's
manipulating are constantly giving him
information about what works. He reads
them and adapts. So, they're affecting
him and modifying his behavior over
time. The result is that he becomes more
and more of whatever works with the
crowd he's manipulating. So, it's a kind
of mutual manipulation. He's programming
them to be what he wants, but they're
programming him to be what they want.
After years of this cycle, the
manipulator behaves in a way that is
most effective with his target audience.
What's most effective with hijab's
target audience? Constantly lying and
acting like a chest thumping caveman.
That's what works with the Dawa fans.
But then hijab after being thoroughly
conditioned to think that constantly
lying and acting like a chestth dumping
caveman is what works goes into a
courtroom where that behavior doesn't
work at all. In fact, in a courtroom,
the behavior that makes you a champion
of da makes you look like a lying,
childish, condescending to
everyone else. And it ends up costing
you £670,000.
small price to pay for the valuable life
lesson though. So this is what's going
on in the DA world, not just with
Muhammad hijab, but with Da in general.
The Daagandists are focused on
impressing their followers. But what's
impressive to the Dawa fans is repulsive
to everyone else. And that's why so many
DA careers are crumbling.
Muhammad Hijab is so desperate that he's
trying to launch an MMA career as a
backup plan. Of course, if that doesn't
work out, he can always go back to his
job as a part-time stripper.
[Music]
>> You
just fine on me. This is a powerful
religion. There's a reason to it. Yeah.
Yeah. Yeah.